Хлопці, ось що залишилося біля мого дому!
Я в боргу не лишився і не лишуся!
Оце їхня техніка!
Прийшли до нас, ***!
Ці кадри 27 лютого 2022 року на вулиці Вокзальній у Бучі
зафільмував 64-річний пенсіонер Валентин Дідковський.
Колона з понад сотні одиниць російської військової техніки спалена вщент.
Як прийшли, так і на той світ пішли!
Отут БТР був розбитий.
Бензовоз цей стояв поперек.
Водій загинув, коли був вибух. І пальне горіло.
Все було поплавлене!
Кадри цієї вулиці з тілами вбитих мирних мешканців тоді шокували цілий світ.
Міжнародна спільнота також дивувалася,
як українці змогли вщент розтрощити важку російську техніку.
Власне, до цього доклав руку і сам пан Валентин
- тодішній член тероборони пригадує,
як гранатометом у власному гаражі допоміг ЗСУ.
Коли я їх побачив, я заскочив у гараж, приготував усе,
по кишеням гранати розкидав.
Ось, де дошки, там причіп стоїть. Там була моя позиція.
І звідти почав діяти!
Валентин зміг влучити гранатами у ворожий бензовоз,
вогонь перекинувся на іншу техніку,
а ЗСУ добили окупантів артилерією.
Моє щастя, що я від воріт відскочив,
коли з причепа відскочив, і почав у них гранати кидати.
Оце мене врятувало.
Там, де я з гранатомета вистрілив,
там такі були простріли, що з мене би там м'ясо залишилося!
Будинок пана Валентина сильно постраждав у тому бою.
Нині з руйнацій - лише дірки у паркані.
Усе інше - пробитий дах, стіни та подвір’я
- пенсіонер відновив самотужки із сином.
Звичайно, в кредит зайшли. Головне, що дах є над головою.
Все інше по-тихеньку зробиться.
Я себе налаштував на те, що допомоги не буде.
Рік тому на цій вулиці частково або повністю були потрощені
всі будинки - на ділянці довжиною у 2 кілометри.
Більшість власників домівок на Вокзальній почали відновлення самотужки,
розповідає сусідка пана Валентина - Галина.
Коштів їй вистачило, щоб відремонтувати лише кілька стін та батареї.
У нас тут ні однієї батареї, нічого не було!
Ми ж оце робили все!
Ось зараз привезе внук гіпсокартон, буде обшивати.
Один лист коштує 400 гривень.
Ми заплатили 70 тисяч за батареї, бо тут діти.
Розбирати завали, відновлювати покрівлі
та робити локальні ремонти безкоштовно допомагали й волонтери
- вони приїздили на вихідних і допомагали хто чим міг,
а на зібрані онлайн пожертви наймали бригади спеціалістів
для капітальних ремонтних робіт.
На Вокзальній це робила і досі продовжує робити команда волонтерів "Сміливі відновлювати".
На Вокзальній наші волонтери були одними з перших,
хто допомагав розбирати завали,
бо там про відновлення будинків майже не йшлося.
Крім українських волонтерів, ще працює багато іноземців.
Минулого року було більше тридцяти іноземців.
І от зараз є 70 іноземців, які вже цієї весни-літа хочуть приїхати до нас
допомагати розбирати завали.
З наближенням весни почали до нас знову сипатися запити,
люди звертаються, просять допомогти.
На поміч мешканцям Вокзальної прийшли також іноземні благодійні фонди,
які надали гроші місцевій владі Бучі.
Приміром, коштом німецького фонду зараз відновлюють будинок і подвір'я пані Тетяни.
Частину будинку демонтували, тому що воно відновленню зовсім не підлягало,
тому будуть ось відбудовувати окремо.
Укріпили стіни, міняють дах.
І навіть стелі, тому що усе провисало.
Слава Богу! Гараж відремонтували. Дякуємо велике!
Весь світ зрозумів, що війна відбувається в центрі Європи.
Вулиця Вокзальна якраз стала символом для кожного громадянина світу.
Чим більше ми оновлюємо, чим більше демонструємо,
що ми робимо і як ми робимо, який результат бачать партнери й інвестори,
тим більше в них бажання і довіра до фінансування.
За словами міського голови Бучі,
на вулиці Вокзальній одночасно ведеться відбудова 112 найбільш пошкоджених об'єктів.
Серед них - 14 будинків будують з нуля.
Перед цим - відновили дорогу, тротуари та місцеву школу.
Загалом за час окупації російськими загарбниками рік тому
місто Буча зазнало збитків від руйнувань на понад 190 мільйонів доларів.
Зокрема пошкоджено більше двох з половиною тисяч житлових споруд.
За даними мерії, аби повністю відновити одну лише вулицю Вокзальну,
потрібні ще додаткові ресурси.
Якщо брати по вулиці, тому що кожен об’єкт має окремий кошторис,
окрему експертизу, і наразі кожне відкриття нового будинку
- це новий проєкт, але ми плануємо так, що десь у 120-150 мільйонів гривень
ми впишемося в такий загальний зведений кошторис.
Це складно, їх ще поки немає.
Нам важливо надзвичайно отримувати зараз не лише солідарність,
не лише співчуття, а і підтримку, фінансову підтримку,
яка дає можливість і перемогти, і відбудуватися в цей час.
Через це ми вдячні кожному і кожній, хто долучився.
Через нестачу коштів на відбудову більшість мешканців Вокзальної
змушені були зимувати у частково розбитих оселях.
Кожен мав змогу подати заявку на компенсацію збитків від держави.
Загалом на Київщині таких звернень нарахували понад 60 тисяч,
повідомляють у комітеті Верховної ради з питань організації державної влади,
місцевого самоврядування, регіонального розвитку та містобудування.
Його голова Олена Шуляк розповідає
- у травні в Україні вступить в силу ухвалений закон про грошові компенсації
з резервного фонду держави та заморожених рахунків російського "Сбербанку".
На них зможуть претендувати лише ті українці,
кому ще не до кінця або взагалі не відновили оселі.
Власники вже відремонтованих будинків теж отримають відшкодування,
але уже за рахунок офіційних репарацій.
Декілька категорій осіб, які перші.
Тому що ми передбачили для них законом першочерговість.
Це родини військовослужбовців, це багатодітні родини,
це особи з інвалідністю і ті, хто зараз уже демобілізований з лав нашої армії.
Ці люди будуть підніматися в черзі вище,
а всі інші в порядку надходження.
Перші кошти вже були сформовані на рахунках - це 17 мільярдів гривень.
Як мешканець вулиці Вокзальної пан Валентин
теж подав заявку на відшкодування завданих збитків.
Але каже, що покладається насамперед на власні сили і сподівається,
що до літа разом із сином самі добудують хату.
Ми, українці, такі люди, ми не любимо безладу.
Звичайно, це було страшно, але по-тихеньку наша вулиця переходить до Європи.
Ви самі бачите, як воно все відбудовується.
Рік тому, коли в Бучі велися бої з окупантами,
Валентин і не сподівався, що від його дому хоч щось залишиться.
А нині каже: вулиця Вокзальна за рік змогла перетворитися із символу руйнацій війни
на символ відбудови України.
Бути свідком цього для пенсіонера - велика честь.